so when you know that you are
about to go back into a new school term
and it's going to be
via remote learning i mean some people
might say hey but everything you do
is online what's the problem i mean do
you really
notice i mean how do you feel at that
thought of going
back into remote learning yeah look i
mean
i do understand what people mean i've
had i guess a lot of practice you know
nine plus years of being able to speak
at a camera and record things and do all
the technology side of it
um but the answer is there is a huge
difference and i remember
um you know say 12 months ago as we kind
of came out of
the first lockdown here in new south
wales and when we returned back into the
classroom and i could see
the smiling faces of my students or not
even the smiling faces sometimes i'd
explain something
and i could read the confusion on their
face and i thought okay eddie you have
not explained that clearly you need to
do that better
even me looking at your face right now
there's a huge difference
to um from that to trying to deliver
learning to sometimes hundreds of
students at a time
and lacking the feedback and the
interaction which you know
we can do this through a chat but it
isn't the same is it and you know being
able to even
sit beside a student i remember teaching
some pre-service teachers people who
were training to be educators
and saying to them they're really
important things that you communicate to
your students
through your tone of voice through your
posture you know even when i remember as
an
early career teacher learning not to
stand over students
but to sit beside them or even kneel
beside them it's the smallest thing but
actually communicates here i am here to
support you
here to learn alongside you not to kind
of frown at your inability to do this
question
those kinds of things are so missed when
we go
on trim remote learning so even though
i'm grateful for how accessible
technology makes learning
like this i'm still craving the time to
be back with my students face
to face and i love that because what
you're just talking about there is what
it means to be human
and of course kindness is part of what
it means to be human
one more question about math eddie you
say it's a misconception that people
have a brain for maths
and the only thing i'd say to that is
really
your um your incredulity is not
surprising to me jane
i do get it though i mean the way i like
to think about it is that
uh this is a a very silly metaphor but
um i have i don't know how much exactly
you can see on the frame but
i have a fairly slender build i'm
never going to be really muscular or
strong
and so it's a fairly natural thing to
say it's like well okay
you're never going to be an athlete
right it's any
that's not what you're built for right
now i think most people
who are listening or watching in will
say yeah maybe
but you could certainly be fitter and
more athletic than you are now
if you did nothing if you just sat on
your butt for all of lockdown
and didn't get out and enjoy the sun as
it turns out
i actually really do enjoy a particular
kind of exercise i'm a long distance
runner
um turns out having a slender build is
really well fit for that
and i guess what my point is bring it
back to maths is that i know
we often might think okay i just was not
able to
crunch numbers really quickly or
memorize formulas
that's a very common experience and my
response to that is yes but that's only
a part
of mathematics i'm going to shift
metaphors for a second but
my three kids they're all very musical
and they love to sing and play the drums
and the piano and the flute
and i love listening to them most of the
time some of their practice
it clearly needs development but when i
think about them playing music
what i love about music is how broad and
diverse it is
uh my son who's a drummer part of the
reason he plays it is his arms are not
long enough
to play a flute which my daughter can i
just needed to find the part of music
that he could enjoy and that he could uh
really grasp
and i think the same is true of
mathematics many of us
believe that mathematics is not for us
because there's just a particular part
of it
that we didn't have a good time learning
at school but i truly believe
anyone can find their place in
mathematics it's like music we just need
to find the songs we enjoy
you are a technology as well as a
mathematics teacher and i wonder do you
ever think about
the kind of world your kids are going to
grow up in i mean this is such a huge
issue
at the moment as we contemplate
artificial intelligence and the
difference between machines and humans
you know
we have abstraction um but but do you
ever kind of
think and perhaps even worry about
a future where your kids will grow up
the short answer is yes i mean i'm not
sure if there are any parents
out there who haven't at least once
contemplated
wow you know if i grew up in the world
that my children are growing up in i
don't know
how i would relate how i would be able
to you know
look anyone in the eye knowing that my
entire life has been catalogued online
through facebook or twitter or snapchat
or whatever it happens to be
um and yeah i think about um yeah my
kids and particularly
social media which is kind of in many
ways what i've
hopefully used to really help a lot of
people um it also has a dark side
i think that every power that humanity
has ever come up with um you know power
is
not moral it depends on how it's used
whether it achieves good
or ill and so i do think with a little
bit of nervousness about the kind of
world my children are walking into
but i also know that this is not
new in a sense um the development of
technology throughout
history um is something which humanity
has always had to wrestle with
and you know it is never going to serve
us to just kind of shrink back and say
well i just don't have the um the time
or the thought or the effort
um or the wisdom to be able to
understand the situation we've got to
process that we've got to work that out
together and find a wise path through it
no matter what it looks like
now i'll just mention to everybody who's
on
this uh virtual conversation that we've
got about
three minutes maybe four minutes if i'm
a little greedy and i
keep wanting to ask any questions so i
hope you'll get ready
and think of questions that you would
like to ask eddie and please use the q
and a
tab for that so i don't have to switch
things around too much that's being
helpful to me
kind to me thank you eddie
you've said that you love being in the
classroom and your intent is to stay
there as long as possible
it's what animates you and gives you
energy
how do you know though that something
else couldn't make you
even happier uh that's a really good
question
uh i mean i guess the most direct way i
can answer that is to say
i don't know there are so many things in
my life which
if i had you know come back from now and
gone to eddie in the past and said hey
guess what this is going to happen i'd
say really
like how how can you i could have a
picture some of the things that have
happened to me
um in the last few years um i couldn't
even have contemplated so
i know enough about myself to know that
the future
holds things of uncertainty and i'm okay
to embrace that
um but i guess you know where is that
that quote that you just mentioned that
conviction
where that comes from is that you know
if there's this funny thing which i know
education
isn't the only uh you know industry that
does this
but we have this funny uh
counter-intuitive counterproductive
habit
of saying wow you are a great teacher
you are fantastic at working with
children in the classroom
i know what we'll do we'll promote you
right out of there and sit you in an
office or put you in some kind of role
of management where actually your skill
set is not that useful
and so me wanting to stay close to the
classroom close to students
is a recognition of the fact that i
think that is where
my core skills are but even like right
now i am not just a
teacher at technology high school i have
the great privilege of working with
the new south wales department of
education and working across schools
broadly
and i like to think and i guess the only
people who will be able to tell me
otherwise the people who i i work with
and who i get to interact with
i like to think that the work i do
outside the classroom is of a better and
a different quality
because i still remain in the classroom
i still have that currency
i still have that understanding of the
unique challenges and joys
of being in front of students wrestling
with curriculum changes as they roll
through that's what's in the news at the
moment
i feel that's a great privilege and i
never want to lose that